la 23e édition du festival jazz à toutes
heures a débuté le 18 mars rendez vous
incontournable du sud yvelines et du
nord essonne cette année le tempo est
donné par un cousin du jazz la tendance
de l'année lé autour du blues est une
musique très facile d'accès très
conviviale fortement et est très varié
si vous aimez le blues vocal avec toute
la puissance de la voix et des émotions
il faut à l'écouté case hawkins quelle
chanteuse irlandaise assez incroyable
ils vont
[Musique]
enfin si vous aimez blues qui déménage
il faudra écouter
non le champ
demain un élément jusqu'au 17 avril jazz
à twitter ces douze concerts sur douze
lieux différents par douze artistes
différents autrefois festival pur jazz
il allie aujourd'hui jazz blues chanson
française pop et même parfois du reggae
parce que c'est le groupe voilà on aime
toutes les musiques et on a envie de les
faire partager quand on fait la
programmation d'un festival ont fait
partager ses passions c'est surtout des
préférences pour les artistes c'est
surtout les coups de coeur pour les
artistes autre axe de l'événement la
découverte de nouveaux talents cette
année l'une des étoiles montantes vient
tout droit de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on parie sur sa marâtre
jeune artiste américaine
festival qui est une chanteuse avec une
voix absolument incroyable à mon avis
elle arrivera au niveau de la fidh
gérald j'ai pas l'habitude de dire ça
pour voir la prodige du jazz vocal
rendez vous le 16 avril à bullion le
reste de la programmation du festival
est à retrouver sur le site jazz à
twitter.com